SIMU LIU
Hey everyone, Simu Liu here,
and I'm with my fellow
castmates Awkwafina and Meng'er
from Marvel Studios' Shang-Chi
and the Legend of the Ten Rings,
and today, we're gonna answer
some rapid-fire questions. You ready?
AWKWAFINA
Let's do this!
MENG'ER ZHANG
Here we go!
AWKWAFINA
Fun.
SIMU LIU
Dangerous.
AWKWAFINA
Frisky.
SIMU LIU
Fierce.
MENG'ER ZHANG
Kick a lot of...
SHANG-CHI
[Grunts]
MENG'ER ZHANG
Oh, sorry, that's too many words.
SIMU LIU
I can move my ears.
MENG'ER ZHANG
I eat a lot. That counts, right?
AWKWAFINA
I can walk into a room and say something
about my acid reflux
and everyone slowly leaves.
SHANG-CHI
Okay.
SIMU LIU
Bungee jumping.
MENG'ER ZHANG
Skydiving.
AWKWAFINA
I've always wanted to jump into a split
when no one was expecting it, like...
[Laughs] Like in Walgreens, you know?
And it's like oh, I can do something.
XIALING
What are you talking about?
SIMU LIU
They play a big role in the origin story
of Iron Man and now you're gonna see how
it factors into this character, Shang-Chi.
MENG'ER ZHANG
It's so heartwarming and so much love.
AWKWAFINA
It is going to show you a part of the MCU
that we have never explored.
SIMU LIU
Action sequences
like you have never seen before.
- Don't miss...
AWKWAFINA
Don't miss Marvel Studios'
Shang-Chi and the
Legend of the Ten Rings.
SIMU LIU
Go see the movie!